bonjour jean marc jancovici c'est donc
le sujet de la rentrée grâce à nicolas
hulot mais on va oublier quelques
minutes nicolas hulot incendie
sécheresses fonte de glaciers dans les
alpes éboulements records de chaleur cet
été en france à paris il ya le feu à la
maison
alors on sait depuis longtemps qui aura
le feu à la maison il est en train de
nous arriver en ce moment ce qui arrive
à un fumeur qui fume depuis 20 ans et à
qui ça fait 20 ans qu'on dit tu sais tu
devrais arrêter et puis un jour il
commençait à dire oh là là j'ai une
sacrée douleur dans le coeur ou bien
j'ai une sacrée douleur dans la jambe ou
bien je viens de passer un scanner là et
ça a vraiment une sale gueule
bah oui donc il est en train de se
passer en ce moment des choses qui sont
parfaitement attendu simplement comme on
est des animaux et qu'on fait plus
confiance à nos sens et votre cervelle
là on est en train de s'en rendre compte
pour de vrai et ça n'est que le début
attendu mais on a l'impression que la
pente est plus forte que le
réchauffement s'accélère alors contre
devrait suivre une trajectoire inverse
objectif je rappelle s'est limitée à
moins de 2 degrés le réchauffement d'ici
la fin du siècle
on n'est pas du tout sur cette
trajectoire d'après l'onu on va vers un
monde à plus de 2 degrés dès 2040 pour
être à deux degrés d'ici la fin du
siècle
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut avoir en
tête et qui est une constante physique
c'est qu'un surplus de co2 concret dans
l'atmosphère aujourd'hui faut attendre
des milliers d'années avant qu'il s'en
aille
quand donc il ya une et réversibilité
totale sur ce genre de processus
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça 2° à
d'ici à la fin du siècle
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on s'arrête
d'émettre sur la planète quelque part
entre 2050 et 2080 qu'on est divisée des
émissions par trois dans les trente cinq
ans qui viennent
voilà ça veut dire des choses comme ça
et ça veut dire en gros qu'il faudrait
que la semaine prochaine on se met sur
une pente d'une baisse de 3% des
émissions par an chaque année 3% - oui
et là ça continue la course à la france
qui s'est engagée à réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 40%
d'ici à 2030 continue de les voir
augmenter c'est le chic la raison à cela
c'est que les gens comprennent pas que
en fait c'est l'économie et l'écologie
sont antagonistes dans cette affaire
alors elles sont pas antagonistes parce
qu'on a envie c'est en cas de listes
parce que c'est comme ça en gros le co2
c'est quoi c'est le résultat du ti
lisation de l'énergie et l'énergie c'est
la nourriture des machines et les
machines c'est ce qui fait la production
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que votre
chemise a été faite par une machine de
votre micro a été fait par une machine
le bifteck que vous allez manger soir a
été transportée en valais découpé par
une machine
tout le monde vit avec des machines en
fait c'est les machines qui produisent
partout et si vous avez moins d'énergie
vous avez moins de machines qui
produisent l'umq l'économie se contracte
l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui sur terre c'est des
combustibles fossiles ça continue à des
combustibles fossiles malgré tout ce
qu'on se raconte en ce moment sur le
solaire l'éolien la production
électrique qui a le plus augmenté sur
les cinq dernières années c'est la
production au charbon de très loin la
conurbation de pétrole continuent
d'augmenter la consommation de gaz
augmente et pour contracter
l'approvisionnement fossiles en fait il
faut au premier ordre contracté
l'approvisionnement énergétique tout
court
c'est à dire mettre au repos une partie
notre exosquelette d'iron man naquit
produit pour nous et donc ses
contraintes et d'économie tout en
quelque sorte la leçon tirée par nicolas
hulot on n'y arrivera pas comme ça dans
ce cadre libéral
écoutons le il faut changer de modèle
disait-il mardi matin sur france inter
on n'a pas compris que c'est le modèle
dominant qui est la cause est-ce qu'on
leur met en cause
j'espère que mon départ provoquera une
profonde introspection de notre société
sur la réalité du monde sur le fait que
l'europe ne gagnera que si l'afrique
gagne remettons les priorités dans le
bon ordre
ce sujet conditionne tous les autres je
le dis en boucle le nucléaire cette
folie inutile économiquement
techniquement dans lequel on s'entête
voilà c'est autant de sujets sur lequel
je n'ai pas réussi en coin j'en prends
ma part de responsabilité alors
plusieurs choses d'abord la folie
nucléaire c'est nicolas hulot plate
s'est il déjà qu'un rapport officiel
remis sa dette au gouvernement l'a pris
le lendemain dans les échos préconise le
lancement de 6 nouveaux réacteurs au
père est ce qu'on va vraiment jean marc
jancovici avoir besoin de ce courant
nucléaire ou est ce que c'est pour
satisfaire les appétits industriel ddf1
encore nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est pour
faire fonctionner les trains les métros
votre frigo et votre machine à laver
c'est à ça que ça sert
[Musique]
on pourra faire autrement parce que si
on est à cergy renouvelables seront
moins chers ça c'est ce que vous pensez
ça n'arrivera pas non c'est pourquoi
parce que le soleil ne brille pas la
nuit par définition que le vent ne
souffle pas quand ya pas de vent et
qu'en fait avec ces énergies
intermittentes le coup de restitution
d'un kilowattheure que vous avez quand
vous en avez envie
vous n'avez pas envie de votre frigo
marche que quand tu es du soleil ou que
le train de 8 heures avant ce que kant
et du vent c'est ce qu'on appelle les
énergies fatales
exactement et à mes amis tentent et ben
pour rendre de nouveau sa pilotable
comme toutes les centrales électriques
on a aujourd'hui le surcoût est
absolument phénoménal dans quand on
parle simplement du coup en sortie de
panneaux ou en sortie d'éoliennes
on a oublié tout le reste de l'histoire
qui est de rendre ce kilowattheure
pilotable de telle sorte que 38 eur par
ta vie tu as jusqu'au moment où on
arrivera à stocker de grandes quantités
des réussites et d'énergie non pas sur
batterie en tout cas quand vous faites
les calculs dans de grandes heures vous
vous rendez compte que la quantité de
batteries qu'il faudrait mettre sur
terre pour y arriver dépasse
l'entendement et je serais mort qu'on
n'en a toujours pas fait le quart de la
moitié donc et en fait ce que je viens
de répondre illustre une grande
difficulté de la gestion ce sujet dans
les médias c'est qu'on est dans le
slogan contre le slogan alors que
l'énergie c'est de la physique et la
physique ça se compte donc en fait on
peut pas sortir de ce genre de débat
sans avoir fait des calculs alors sa
barque les auditeurs et calcul des
règles de trois des machins détruite
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on nous emmerde avec
les chiffres
malheureusement il faut en passer par là
donc c'est le drame de ce sujet c'est
que tout le reste en dépend et que c'est
un sujet très technique et qu'il faut
prendre le temps de rentrer dedans et
sans ça on n'y arrive pas sur le
changement de modèles sai a raison la
question posée par hulot c est ce qu on
peut concilier le libéralisme la
croissance économique et la transition
écologique est ce qu'on peut être en
même temps pro business et pro planète
alors au business et pro planète wipro
croissance et pro planète non il faut
inventer et de décroissance dont combat
de façon va y avoir droit il faut bien
voir qu'aujourd'hui la raison pour
laquelle on pense qu'on a de la
croissance c'est parce que quand on
produit quelque chose en fait on
consomme de la nature votre chemise a
été fait et du coton le génome du coton
la nature nous l'a donnée gratuitement
si elle est faite avec des fibres
synthétiques c'est du pétrole pétrole la
nature nous l'a donnée gratuitement vous
allez rentrer chez vous c'est fake des
pierres les pierres sont apparus
gratuitement dans la nature on n'a pas
on avait une terre avec des pierres
dedans et c'est donc il faut bien voir
que la production économique en fait
utiliser des ressources naturelles que
nous n'avons jamais payer tout ce qu'on
paye dans l'économie c'est des hommes
c'est l'effort des hommes qu'on paye les
oraux de le paye que des hommes et de la
russie donc quand on pense que le pib
augmente et donc il ya de la croissance
économique en fait c'est de la
transformation des ressources qui
augmente mais du coup on les détruit ses
ressources et donc ça peut pas durer
indéfiniment
donc en fait tous les modèles qu'on fait
qui intègre la physique dans l'économie
vous montre qu'après la croissance sera
de la décroissance ça peut pas être
autrement
et donc la seule bonne question c'est
est-ce que j'ai amorti le système le
plus vite possible de ma propre volonté
et d'un port phh a à c est ce que
j'accepte tout de suite la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat contre le fait que
l'espèce humaine dure le plus longtemps
possible
où est ce que je dis ce type raconte que
des conneries le pouvoir d'achat n'est
pas question de le baisser et à ce
moment là fête durera pas très longtemps
que vous êtes d'accord avec nicolas
hulot il faudra changer nos modes de vie
nos modes de grosses chances et de tout
face à venir ils vont changer de toutes
façons contraint forcé pour tout le
monde mais parce qu'il y aura une
minorité privilégiée qui pourra que se
la payer des voyages au bout du monde
sûr que si on en fait partie mais bien
sûr que si bien sûr que si mais parce
que les sociétés humaines ont toujours
été inégalitaire quelle que soit la
manière dont les inégalités s'est
produite mais par contre le drame
politiquement indicible de cette affaire
delà de la façon dont on a construit
l'économie c'est que le mode de vie du
smicard n'est pas durable avec 7
milliards de smicards sur la planète ça
mange pas comment vous l'imaginez ou
comment vous le souhaitez le prochain
ministre de l'environnement deux du
gouvernement français
si on s'amuse à faire le mouton à cinq
pattes il faut que ce soit quelqu'un qui
ait une capacité à s'imprégner de la
science parce que la description de
l'état de l'environnement c'est de la
science avant tout un don qu'il faut
qu'ils s'en imprègne sans perdre du
temps à le remettre en cause
qu'il s'agisse de la biodiversité des
poissons du changement climatique ou du
nucléaire faut pas s'amuser à remettre
en cause la science on nous donne des
constants est propre la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut bien connaître les
acteurs de l'économie parce que les gens
qui consomment de la nature comme dit
brice lalonde ces entreprises donc il
faut bien connaître le fonctionnement
économique il faut bien connaître
fonctionnant réglementaire faut avoir
envie d bataille au couteau avec ses
petits copains parce que ministre de
l'environnement c'est un métier qui
consiste à en garder tout le monde
loïc départ mais bursa et nicolas
s'était pas du tout sa tasse de thé que
d'aller à l'aide de couteaux et enfin il
faut avoir l'oreille du président et il
faut lui faire comprendre qu'il a
quelque part pas le choix est en tout
cas ma conviction profonde c'est que
s'ils veulent laisser son nom dans
l'histoire il n'a pas le choix c'est à
dire que s'il fait de la gestion des
affaires courantes comme il était en
train de faire en ce moment avec
j'occupe des déficits budgétaires dans
trois ans enfin deux ans après qu'il ait
quitté l'élysée on aura oublié jusqu'à
son nom parce que ça marchera pas mieux
que les autres
s'il veut laisser son nom dans
l'histoire il a un projet c'est celui-là
c'est comme un mouton à cinq pattes ou
un portrait introuvable merci jean marc
jancovici j'appelle vous êtes ingénieur
associé d'un cabinet de conseil en
transition énergétique carbone 4 et
président du think tank de shift project
merci d'avoir été avec nos styles